كانت والدتي التي
ربتني وأختي امرأة
فخورة كانت امرأة بنية اللون كانت امرأة
بلكنة ثقيلة
وكانت والدتها شاملا جوبالان أيضًا
التأثير الأكبر
في حياة كاملا هاريس
بعد الإعلان الكبير الذي
كتبته أخت هاريس في منشور على تويتر
لا يمكنك معرفة من هي كاملا هاريس
دون معرفة من كانت والدتنا
في عام 1958 ، سافرت غوبالان الهندية البالغة من العمر 19 عامًا على بعد
آلاف الأميال من
منزلها
وعائلتها للحصول على الدكتوراه في التغذية وعلم
الغدد الصماء في أمريكا ، وسرعان ما أصبحت
حقوقًا مدنية نشطة  الصليبية أثناء
دراستها
في جامعة كاليفورنيا في بيركلي بمجرد ذهابها إلى هناك
، شعرت بالحرية تقريبًا
وشاركت في السياسة التي
اعتادت إحضار سلسلة كاملة من
الأدب اليساري الأدبي من
كارل بوبر حتى تعرف أنه كان فيلسوفًا عظيمًا
في كتابها يقول هاريس هناك  ليس هناك
لقب أو شرف على الأرض سأعتز به
أكثر من القول
إنني ابنة شاملا جوبالان
هاريس ، وزيارات هاريس إلى الهند مع والدتها
أبقتها على اتصال  إلى جذورها ، عمل
جدها الذي كان لديه آراء قوية حول
القضايا الإنسانية
عن كثب مع المسؤولين لإعادة
توزيع اللاجئين ،
كان لمحادثاتهم تأثير قوي
عليها ، حيث أن المشي على طول الشاطئ في
الهند
زرع شيئًا ما في ذهني بالفعل
وخلق التزامًا في داخلي
قبل أن أدرك ذلك.  لقد قادني
إلى حيث أنا اليوم
، عم هاريس ،
جوبالان بالاشاندران ، الذي يعيش في دلهي ، يخبرنا
كيف يتحول السناتور
إلى والدتها ، مما يعني أن الأم في
التاميل
للحصول على التوجيه حتى بعد وفاتها
قالت فخورة ما الذي
تخبرني به كل ما أفعله أسأل
نفسي
هل توافق أنجما على هذه الكاملا باللغة
الهندية تعني زهرة اللوتس
وهي رمز مهم في الثقافة الهندية
متجذرة في أعماق قاع النهر
تشبه إلى حد بعيد
هوية هاريس الهندية التي هي
ترتدي على كمها